Gregor Mendel’s experiments were a breakthrough
in the field of Biology as they helped in
laying the foundation of Genetics.
Questions like “Why do kids look similar
to their parents” and “Why are there a
few differences in 2 kids that belong to the
same parents?” started gaining answers.
We now have understood the Monohybrid cross
and the monohybrid ratio as well.
This is how it is done!
Take a moment to review it!
How did we get the F one generation?
We got it by considering all the possible
combinations here.
But is there a method to find it systematically?
Yes!
So before moving ahead with the Dihybrid cross
and ratio, let us have a look at an extremely
important and useful method for writing a cross.
The method is named as Punnett square ! You
may wonder why we need one more method for
a theoretical cross, when we already know
how a cross is carried out…
Well, that is because this method is quite
useful in many ways.
The technique was developed by the British
geneticist Reginald Punnett . Hence it is
most commonly known as Punnett square.
Let us understand the technique step by step first.
The first thing we do is, make a table like this!
We write the symbols of male and female here.
These can be written vice versa as well, but
for now we write it like this!
This tells us that the maternal alleles will
be written here while the paternal alleles
will be written here.
So let us begin the crossing now!
This allele can come together with this one
to give us this set of genes in the offspring.
These two can give us this set.
This one will combine with this to give us this set.
And what about the last one?
Yes!
You guessed it right!
These two alleles can give us this set in the offspring.
It’s a simple concept of respective row
and column pairing for each slot.
For this slot, it’s the first row and the first column.
For this slot, it’s the first row and the
second column pairing… and so on!
Please understand this well because it is
going to help us a lot in the future!
Now, if we compare the simple cross that we
usually carry out, this is what we get.
Notice that the results are exactly the same.
All the plants in the F1 generation are tall,
and have the same genotype.
They are all heterozygous!
This confirms that our cross is correct!
A glance at the presentation of this cross
hints at one more name for it!
Yes!
This technique is also referred to as the
checkerboard method .
Now, let us do this cross one more time to
know whether we have understood it correctly!
Let us cross any two from the F1 generation now.
Again, we first draw these lines to form a
table and write the male and female symbols
here.
Now it’s the turn of the genes.
So we write the respective genes here and here.
Shall we begin crossing now?
Why don’t you try filling in these 4 slots?
Here we go!
These are the combinations that we obtain
on crossing these plants.
Take a moment to go through this table.
Can you find the phenotypic and genotypic
ratios here?
Phenotype if you remember, refers to observable
physical properties.
We can clearly see that there are three tall
plants and one dwarf plant.
So the phenotypic ratio is three to one!
What about the genotype?
There is one homozygous tall case, two heterozygous
tall cases, and one homozygous recessive case!
So the genotypic ratio is one to two to one!
Aren’t these the monohybrid ratios?
Yes!
We get exactly the same results that we obtained
on crossing the F1 generation previously.
So, this is how monohybrid cross can be carried
out using the Punnett square method.
Can you guess why this method is used when
we can cross the alleles directly?
Yes, of course we can find it directly…
but that’s because a monohybrid cross involves
the crossing of a single character at a time!
Hence it’s easy!
But what about the crosses that involve more
than one character?
An increase in the number of genes can make
the crossing a bit complicated.
Say we have two or three genes.
Then do you think a simple cross like this
will be convenient to carry out?
Of course not!
It will be a huge mess!
So in order to simplify this, we make use
of a Punnett square.
This method is simple and extremely useful
when more than one alleles are involved!
Talking about crosses involving more than
one character, what are crosses involving
2 characters called?
The cross involving two characters at a time
is called a Dihybrid cross and the ratio obtained
will be a Dihybrid ratio.
Let us understand this interesting concept
in the next part!
Here is a representative monohybrid cross
on our screen which involves only one character
at a time.
Do you think crossing a single character at
a time was enough for Mendel to arrive at
concrete conclusions?
Of course not!
After all the seven pairs of contrasting characters
were crossed individually, Mendel went a step
ahead and crossed plants considering two characters
at a time.
He tried the DIHYBRID cross .
Let us take a simple example to understand
how the Dihybrid cross works!
Which two characters should we take now?
We have already seen a monohybrid cross for
characters like the plant height and the flower
colour individually.
So let us consider these characters together
to understand the Dihybrid cross.
For our convenience, we take one plant which
has both dominant characters while the other
with both having recessive characters.
It means we take both the plants which are
HOMOZYGOUS . Any guesses about what the genotypes
will be?
“TTPP” in upper case will be this plant
which is tall, with purple coloured flowers.
Similarly, “ttpp’’ in lower case will
represent a plant that is dwarf and has white
coloured flowers.
This is how we separate the gametes.
Any idea why didn’t we write it as TT and PP?
The alleles T and T represent the same trait.
So they will have to be distributed in the
respective gametes.
They will not get together in the same cell.
Similarly...
P and P will get into the separate cells as
they are the alleles for the same trait flower
colour!
It’s the same case in the other plant as well.
This is how the gametes will be formed!
Now we’re ready for the crossing!
This is how the F1 generation would look.
Take a moment to understand this!
Now to get a conclusive result, we need to
cross the offsprings from the F1 generation
and get the F2 generation.
Let’s pick any two from the F one generation!
Can you tell me how the gametes will be formed here?
The gametes can be formed in these four different
combinations for each case!
Did you notice what happened?
Will it be easy to do the crossing here?
Definitely not!
That is the reason why we opt for
‘Punnett square’ for a Dihybrid cross.
Let us get started with the cross for obtaining
the F2 generation.
We write the male and female symbols first.
Followed by this, we write the respective
gametes here and here.
And how do we cross these to fill in the 16 slots?
We cross each row and column respectively.
Here, this “TP” is crossed with this “TP”.
So we obtain this slot.
Similarly, we cross this “Tp” with “TP”
to get this offspring.
Can you try filling in the third and fourth
slots in the first column?
We cross this “tP” with this “TP”
to obtain this offspring, and lastly, we cross
this “tp” with this “TP” to obtain
this one!
All 4 as we can see in the table, are tall
with purple flowered plants.
That’s because there is at least one capital
T and one capital P in each case!
If you wish to, you could pause the video
to fill in the other 12 slots.
On similar lines, these are the results that
we obtain in the other slots!
Take a moment to go through all of these!
Let’s count the different combinations now!
These are the four different possible combinations.
‘Tall with purple flowered plants’, ‘tall
with white flowered plants’, ‘dwarf with
purple flowered plants’, and ‘dwarf with
white flowered plants’.
Now can you count the number of plants that
are tall and with purple flowers?
We have nine plants which are tall and with
purple coloured flowers.
Can you count the number of plants for the
other 3 combinations?
Three plants show the tall trait along with
white flowers; and three show the dwarf trait
along with purple flowers.
Six plants in all have mixed characters of
the parents from the P1 generation.
It means at least one recessive character
is seen in these 6 plants.
Now, the last one among the sixteen shows
both the recessive traits: a plant which is
dwarf and has white flowers.
So if taken together, then we obtain a ratio
9 to 3 to 3 to 1 . This ratio is referred
to as the Dihybrid Ratio .
Nora has a simple question for you now!
Whenever any two characters are randomly taken
for a cross, do we obtain the same ratio?
Say we take the seed colour and the seed shape
will we obtain the same ratio?
Well, if the cross is carried out correctly,
then we are bound to get ‘9 to 3 to 3 to
1’ as the Dihybrid ratio!
So if there are sixteen plants obtained in
the F2 generation, then 9 of them on an average
will express both the dominant characters.
Like the tall height and purple coloured flowers
in this case!
6 plants on an average will express a blend
of both the characters: dominant and recessive.
Just like these 3 expressing tall height and
white flowers, and these 3 showing dwarf height
and purple flowers!
Lastly, only one out of the sixteen shows
both recessive characters!
Do you think we always get exactly 16 plants
in the F2 generation?
No not at all!
There are numerous seeds obtained, which are
then sown, and plants are grown to observe
these results!
Did Mendel get only 16 plants in the F2 generation?
This is also not the case!
Mendel had obtained many seeds.
But when he grew plants from them, he obtained
the plants in certain numbers.
When these numbers were calculated, the ratio
turned out to be 9 to 3 to 3 to 1.
So basically, 9 to 3 to 3 to 1 is the RATIO
obtained at the end of calculations!
The total number of seeds and thus the plants
obtained could be much higher.
Do watch our videos based on Ratios if you
want to understand them better!
So 9 to 3 to 3 to 1 is the phenotypic ratio
for a Dihybrid cross!
Before we get deeper into Mendelian experiments,
let us have a look at the laws put forth by
Mendel.
Based on the observations of Monohybrid and
Dihybrid crosses, Mendel established three
extremely important LAWS in genetics.
In the next part, let us have a look at them!
Don’t forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel in order to get notified!